If there is a product that someone else recommended that I take, is that okay?
Um, again, remember this, this is your choice in your cancer care.
We're not, uh, my way or the highway type clinic.
I only asked that you run it by me.
Um, I've had people that, um, maybe don't watch the Zoom calls at all.
Don't look at our website at all.
And then I find out after I haven't spoken to them for a long, long time.
They, um, that they're taking things that they really shouldn't take.
Um, like glutathione or methylated nutrients or something like that.
Um, and it was recommended by a naturopath or their car practor or something who doesn't understand the nuances of cancer.
And so I don't want you taking things that you shouldn't take.
Of course, you could do whatever you want to do, but at least I want to give you the right advice.
I mean, you're part of our clinic and we want to take care of you.
So whereas in one aspect, you could do whatever you want to do.
Another aspect is I feel it's a shame if you don't at least get our advice.
Whether you feel like God's leading you in a different direction or not, I want you to be obedient to him, ultimately.
But, um, I certainly don't want you making a decision based upon fear or pressure, peer pressure or pressure from another practitioner.
It's got a very, very strong personality and it's telling you, oh my gosh, you should be taking glutathione, you have cancer.
Whether it's, if they said that phrase that it's obvious they know nothing about cancer and they shouldn't be giving you advice, period.
Let alone giving any cancer patient advice, but at least if you do get recommended supplements from another practitioner, my suggestion as you say.
I get a way to buy it and I'll take a picture of it and I'll send it to Dr. Cutters and run it by him if he thinks it's okay then.
Or if I would have prey about it and I feel like this is exactly what I was supposed to shake regardless of what other what Dr. Cutter says.
Don't do so, but don't be pressured into doing anything even by your oncologist.
Don't let anybody pressure you into anything. Don't let me pressure you into anything.
Make the decisions. We're called to use wisdom. So we're called to seek wisdom and wisdom is applied knowledge.
So, you know, I study and study constantly to better serve you and but but wisdom is also applied knowledge that the Holy Spirit can apply to our hearts too.
So, it's not just applied by other people and then we're taking that information and trying to apply it to everyday life, but it's it's information that is going to be best suited for us.
So we want to have peace about all our decisions that we make, but we want to base them on intelligence. God has desired us to use the brain that he's given us and use the resources that he's given us.
He's called some to be apostles, some to be teachers, some to be prophets, some to be evangelists, et cetera.
And he's called some to be, you know, you know, we put ourselves under people like doctors to help us guide us because we can't know everything.
You know, I don't try to do masonry work when that's not my specialty.
Okay, fair, I do try to do masonry work even if it's not my specialty, but that's another story.
So, we want to utilize the gifts that we have and utilize other people's gifts and then be prayed about it and ask God for wisdom and peace about all our decision making processes.
So, all I ask is that if you're getting recommendations from somebody else, you just run it by me and we'll talk about it.